[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys
and welcome back to the lehigh show
powered by icon
plus as usual so a quick message from
them if you are tired of high gas fuse
um on unisop then you can now swap your
ethereum based tokens on
icon through orbit chain so all you have
to do if you want to do that is visit
bridge.orbitchain.io and then try it out
i also want to say thank you to block by
they are one of my sponsors
um i use them to earn up to 8.6
interest on my usdc so that's insane 8.6
interest um right now you have negative
interest rates across europe um i think
it's pretty terrible in the states as
well
in england you've got 0.01 so if you can
get 8.6
interest and that's amazing um so i'm
going to leave the link
everywhere for you you can get 250
dollars when you sign up so that's
really cool
and also before we start the show
because this one is a little bit
different so it's going to be pretty
cool
um i want to say another huge shout out
to coinflip they sponsor the show um
and they're doing some incredible work
across the states to push bitcoin mass
adoption they now have 1
400 bitcoin atms um giving access to
every day pic
everyday people which i think is really
cool so i have a 10
discount code if you guys want it and
i'll leave that in the comments
so joining me today is a pretty
interesting guest somebody
that i met through twitter but i have
actually been able to meet in real life
as well
he is kind of known as convict turned
conqueror pretty interesting oh i think
he's he's actually just gone i'm not
sure why he's gone
let's just find out why i can't get him
hang on oh
there we go he's back he's back is bobby
back
oh wow bobby there you go i don't know
what happened i hit the retweet and it
just went
poof and i was gone so i missed it
yeah no you're here on time you're here
perfectly on time
how are you doing i'm doing well i'm
doing a lot and yourself
yeah i'm good i'm good so you are
really interesting um you call yourself
convict turned us i want to get into all
of that but before we do
i've got we've got to talk about bitcoin
because right now it's almost hitting
40k
and i know you're a little bit into
crypto so just
give me your thoughts i mean a little
bit yeah i i
totally uh am behind the movement i
recommend it to people
um i i really started studying it back
in march like right when covet hit
and started reading what people were
were putting out there about it and not
not no offense to people that are on
social media but not necessarily social
media
talking heads more like you know the
financial experts and
and whatnot and um and saw that it was
it was going to go places so i got into
it uh told
others they should get into it which
just it's made me feel like this
financial wizard
because i've had more than a couple
people tell me like
man you really called it on on the
bitcoin bro like that
like it's crazy you know and it it has
been it's great
awesome yeah it's it's absolutely insane
especially you know if you started in
march 2020 then wow you've got to see
the rise of like
over 20 grand in one year like that's
insane
um but i want to kind of go back a
little bit and understand
a little bit about you because we met
through twitter
but we had the chance to meet in romania
and you know you call yourself convict
time congress so
what does that mean why are you across
what happened to
us well okay so so back in 2000
uh i was leading kind of this hedonistic
lifestyle to where i was doing
illegal activity um i was just
not really caring about anyone or
anything else about myself
and i got into an altercation and wound
up
going to prison in california i was
there
for originally for five years but then
got into some more problems while i was
in and had to end up doing a decade
total and um about halfway through
i just i came to this realization you
know
i'm reading these different books and
self-help books and whatnot and i came
to this
realization like wow man everything's on
me i got to take responsibility for my
life you know this isn't other people's
problems this is my problems i got to
fix it
so it was just this turning point for me
and um
i i essentially stopped running around
with the people that were in there and
and just
went off on my own uh did some studying
got into some vocations
uh lined up a job for when i got out and
uh
really kind of just hit the ground
running and
everything that i've put my mind to
since then once i once i came to that
realization that
okay you got to take responsibility for
everything and you have to commit
you know you have to follow through do
it it's like there hasn't been anything
that's
that i haven't been able to do so that's
what i talk to people about they they
find it inspiring for me it's just you
know
the life i've lived but you know i mean
it
you could do what you put your mind to
and that's that's the hurdle that a lot
of people have that
it's true that you there's just so many
examples that you can't deny it
so what happened you know
you said you sort of got mixed up with
the wrong people and
you sort of say that you know you had
that turning point so can you take us
through the journey how did it start and
what was that
sort of turning point inside i know you
said you did longer than you expected
right
yeah so uh
i can't i i come from people that
uh and and them uh
have been associated with people my
whole life
that the law enforcement would
would consider like a criminal type
element okay um
like like an organized criminal type
element
so uh from from a young age i i saw the
kind of um i don't want to say glamour
because it's not necessarily glamorous
but i saw the kind of cool lifestyle
uh that there was and um you know the
people
that were around and all that and so uh
it made me want to get into it i got
into it while i was still in high school
you know started doing little different
different jobs you know
and um and was getting stacks of money
you know and so uh it was something that
was appealing but at the same time
i always knew it was wrong
and so then i started getting into
things to cope with that
you know um i i started uh not drinking
like
like um like gnarly but you know i
started drinking alcohol i started
smoking pot you know i was doing all
these different things to kind of just
numb that
that away um and then when i did when i
did end up going to prison
you know i went in thinking like okay i
gotta do what i have to do
you know like i'm not you know this is a
it's a hardcore place
so you have to handle your business and
if something comes up or you got to
defend yourself or you got to fight or
whatever it is you just do what you got
to do
and that's what i did and i i did that
for for five years
and what ended up happening um
was about four years in
um i was hanging out with some guys
that uh we were in our little work area
our workshop
and these guys were having um free staff
uh which are um prison employees that
aren't
the corrections officers you know right
uh they were having
these free staff bring them in pot and
different drugs and whatever
and so we were in the shop and the cops
came in
and uh they they found a baggie
with with like the residue of some pot
in it
and they found it near me okay so
uh and they were like oh this is yours
and i'm like no it's not you know and
they mirandize me which um
for for american speak that's just when
they go uh you have the right to remain
silent
anything you oh your miranda rights
right yeah yeah right
yeah so so so they they they ran my
miranda rights down to me and as soon as
they did that i was like
okay i want a lawyer you know like i'm
not i don't have anything to say
you know and that pot was uh point
zero zero zero
one grams okay it was an unusable amount
it was it was literally like the residue
inside of a bag like if you would empty
the bag you know like held it upside
down and
dumped it all out what would still be
left in there that little just
crap yeah crumbs yeah uh right so
uh so they they charged me
uh took me to court and and i i was like
well i got this beat
you know that's why i so i i took it to
trial i'm like i got this beat
you know it's not on me it's you know
whatever
and one of the cops got up on the stand
and he said oh yeah he admitted it was
his and
um you know he did that oh yeah like
you know i mean they do that stuff all
the time but like i mean
yeah so um so i ended up getting uh
six years added on to my sentence and uh
yeah it was crazy because um i went in
for
you know what's essentially a violent
crime you know it was it was an assault
with a great bodily injury
uh and i got more time for the residue
in that bag than i did for like
hurting someone so it was a crazy thing
you know
but but even then right like later
later on you know about a year later i'm
kind of reading these books and going
through stuff myself and just getting
sick
with the whole situation even
with that i have to take responsibility
for that
you know like like i was messing around
with those dudes in the shop
okay i'd smoke some of that weed with
them you know what i mean like i was
i was partying with them and everything
like that like if i would
if i would have been totally away from
them you know
not having anything to do with people
like that none of that would have
so i still have to take responsibility
for that i know people hear that you
know they hear the amount and then they
go
six years for five you know they get
like call you know but it's like
yo man i put myself there and that's
part of what i mean when i say taking
responsibility
is you really have to direct your life
and it sounds so easy
when you say it right but that's some of
the
hardest thing that the majority of the
population
has uh you know to do it's like
something that
it's just a real stumbling block for
people
yeah it is and i think that's one of um
the biggest
issues that we're seeing in society now
particularly when we talk about when
people sort of talk about the decline of
the west um because you know
people are just unable to do that i mean
even if we look at the education system
um it's sort of from a young age we're
not taught to take responsibility
particularly when we have things like
participation trophies
then it's kind of like you know you you
don't even take responsibility for
the losing because you're still sort of
rewarded and a kind of perverse
way if that makes sense yeah yeah
totally
you know um it's just it's this really
um there's this
this softness that has been created
um in society by just trying to remove
the element of violence and death
and and you know any anything bad right
so we just pretend that it doesn't exist
and what happens is it makes people soft
you know that's why you see people that
um
and not necessarily everyone but you see
many uh
that have like either been in war or
been in prison for that matter or been
through
through some you know maybe maybe their
their uh
you know police officers or whatever
just people that have
seen the underbelly you know what i mean
and
um those people tend to just
kind of be able to take you know and
move forward with life
right you know they just they handle
what needs to be done
you know i mean i can even tell you in
the in the uk as an example
we have a lot of um we have a lot of
immigrants that come from ex-soviet
countries
and they uh and i've met a lot of them
they're all fantastic
and they have a very different mindset
when it comes to covid
in that they don't care they just don't
care because because they've been
through enough
you know like they've been through
enough they you know their parents grew
up
in absolute poverty under communism and
so on and so when it comes to covid
that's the least of their worries you
know it's just a different mentality
but you mentioned this shady officer or
whatever so
what's it actually like inside so how
tribal is it like i'm gonna be honest
you know like is it like the movies is
it you know
super tribal whether it be like
segregated by race religion
um you know men just just too much
testosterone in one place like
what's it like okay so so let me let me
throw this disclaimer out there
right now okay i was in california state
prison
um that's that's known as being a pretty
gnarly place
okay there are 50 states in in the
united states so
what i speak about in california might
be different
for kansas or for something else i don't
know you know so i'm just gonna speak to
my situation uh okay so
so i didn't really know what racism was
until i went to prison
because it is everything is race like
everything
and it's it's so
stringent that
there are these weird barriers that you
just can't cross
right um like for example
let's say let's say a black guy is
smoking a cigarette
right and he offers you a hit or
whatever you can't take a hit off of
that cigarette
why not not a sick well
the black it's the black guy's cigarette
his mouth offering it to you
same with the drink like let's say
they've got a drink of water or
they've got a drink you can't drink off
of that same
that same cup even if he's offering it
to you yeah right
i mean it is that racial right who would
have the problem
as a white person would you have the
problem or would the the black
people have a problem who would have an
issue from you
that's kind of funny because because um
because really it would be a white issue
because i know
okay i knew that like some of these
black og's
you know when we say og we just mean you
know some older guy that's been in the
game for a minute
handles his stuff right they would do
that type of stuff on purpose to white
guys like when they talk to us
i'd be like they'd be like hey man you
want a drink you know hey you want they
try and trip
them up because they know they knew that
that
there was these rules that were followed
right
but to get back about how it was it was
super duper
racial and you know we're feeling too
uh being a white guy from orange county
which is a uh
like a republican beach county that's
you know right next door to la and in
southern california
um i never really experienced racism
coming
towards me you know i'd seen it going
like away from me like you know towards
other people
but yeah like once i've been in there
and and it is very heavily i mean it's
you know there's there's white people
there too but i mean black and mexican
you know i mean there's all different
types of ethnicities right
and feeling it like coming towards me
you know
and it was weird because um
because it was so racial like that and
so segregated you really felt
kind of like the hate uh a lot of times
coming off of people
you know people trying to make light of
it while you're in there you know you
could bs
play cards joke do whatever
go work out but the reality of it is
it's a prison is a place that's kind of
built on despair
you know it's just you're here you got
to be here you can't go anywhere
try and leave will kill you uh and i
mean that's just it is what it is
you know we're gonna have riots and
we're gonna do this and that and
yeah it's just it's not a fun place i
don't recommend anybody going there
yeah i mean it's really interesting you
know when you
of course you know you mentioned about
prison but i think that's a huge
difference between the us
and the uk everything is so racial
everything is
based on those lines i just think it's
because of the history of the country um
we don't have that it's so incredible
and i talked to a lot of americans about
it and
we don't have that divide between the
two races nobody really
cares we're sort of british before
anything else like
it's insane that i think that you guys
say african-american like if you said
if you said like african british people
would just be like excuse me
like it's almost offensive it's crazy
yeah it is you know um it's kind of like
i remember when i was growing up uh my
my grandfather wouldn't say
italian-american right because uh he
he was an american italian he was an
american with italian heritage right
exactly he he had pride in that
uh yeah so yeah i i get that and you'd
think
california being as progressive as it is
that it wouldn't be that way but it is
california state prisons are
are just gnarly nasty places
and there's bad stuff that happens all
the time and it's super duper racial
um you know the weird thing is is they
have all these race rules right
but all those go out the window when
right
comes into play so oh okay
right so you can't be friends you can't
do whatever this and that but
but wait the the the mexicans have dope
you know or they've got this or that
okay we can talk and go away
so you know that's where a lot of the
the riots would start from
would be that somebody got something
from another race
they remade on paying you know they
didn't pay their bill
uh and then um it built up and the two
end up going at it you know so
essentially it's over debt
so then how how does somebody reform
right because you know you you have in
your twitter bio
convict and conqueror how do you get
from convicts or conqueror how can how
can you reform though because
people either come out of two ways right
they either come out how you've come out
or
they sort of do it all again or they've
been in so long
like the famous film shawshank
redemption and they become
institutionalized and they don't want to
leave
after all you know so how do you get to
that
how do you win in the end you know well
you have to put in the work you have to
have a want
and desire you can't especially people
that are
going down that road to where they found
themselves in prison because believe it
or not
prison is a rock bottom for some people
you think that would be
their rock bottom it's not god i'm
locked up but for some people that ain't
it
like they still they still have a
journey they gotta make
so uh when you see people come going
down that road
you can't pick them up and take them off
and
they either can steer away and kind of
listen to what you have to say to them
or or not
so you have to have that desire to want
to change
your life and then from there there's
certain
there's certain avenues that you can
take advantage of as long as you
recognize them
and are willing to jump on them and what
what i mean by that is this
um okay everybody
in prison is assigned a job detail and
that's what you have to do you know
you get up you go to the job and that's
how you get some time taken off your
sentences
that you go to work right yeah they also
have the
education and vocations right so the
place that i was at
had a vocational welding and machine
shop
and yeah and i know that the
the job that i i had lined up for me
when i got out and that i could do that
was part of what they did was welding
so i was like okay here's where i can
build some skills right here and have
something for when i get out
so you have to be able to
to adapt and recognize
in your situation what it is that you
need to do
um i have a story there's a website for
those uh it's listed right there
bobbydyno.com there
there's um some some blog articles i
have there
i'm gonna ask you about this yeah where
i recount some of the
you know my experiences and one of those
is
where i i had to walk away from the
the race group you know and that's uh
that's a tricky situation because it's
not
like if you don't believe in if if you
don't believe in yourself and have the
conviction
to do it or like if you come up like
kind of half ass
or whatever uh you can find yourself in
trouble
you know it's like you're either hot or
cold but don't be
lukewarm you know don't be right in the
fence and uh it's
i don't know that everybody could do it
the way that i did it
but i know that uh if people really have
the desire they can do it somehow does
that make sense
like yeah it does it does i think like
you have to
really want it it's like anything
difficult in life like you have to have
that desire
um but i guess not everybody has enough
desire to sort of go out and actually
put in the work and make that change but
speaking of your blog um i was going
through it the other day and there are
some pretty interesting stories on there
um there was one story which i want to
ask you about if you could tell us in
the most pc way possible
about a big gay steve gay
yeah tell us about that one okay so so
another disclaimer all the names have
been
changed but but uh
yeah so there's this guy um there was
this guy big gay steve and he was
like football player big like football
like like and i mean american football
uh like linebacker big um i mean this
guy
i'm 6'4 and 240 pounds and i looked
small next to this
oh wow yeah like he had he had this is
crazy
okay he had 20 inch
forearms like his his forearms which one
most dudes don't have 20 inch biceps
you know like a 20 inch bicep you know
you're looking
or you're looking all right you know for
the arms and he was bigger
he's much bigger than you because you're
like gigantic for those that don't know
like bobby is
huge so he was he was like six
six or something like that like he was
taller than me
yeah and he was just very big i mean i
think i want to say he weighed like 340
or 350 pounds
like that's i weigh 240. so i mean yeah
this dude was just
he was big um like nfl big you know
and um so he
was one of the guys that was considered
an enforcer
for obvious reasons so like let's say
you're a new guy
they call them fish your fish rolling up
to the yard
right uh your white guy
they want to see your paperwork they
want to see your what you're in for
we used to call them a 128 because that
was the what the
form the number of the form was you know
so we'd say let me see your 128 right so
you
check their paperwork um he was one of
those guys that did that
you know uh he was uh he was he was a
beast and he was one of those
guys too that uh he and he enjoyed
the role right so it it was like i
at first when i first met him he didn't
come off as a bully
but he enjoyed being the guy that people
were afraid of
and as i knew steve uh he just got kind
of got progressively worse and things
with him got weird
uh people can read this story i don't
want to give it all away you know but
essentially
uh he he started bullying people
for different things uh first it was
their their property
uh later it was you know uh allegedly
for other stuff
yeah and and uh he was someone that
we didn't want somebody like that around
okay
um are you familiar with jeffrey dahmer
no okay so jeffrey dahmer was this guy
in america
that was like he was a serial killer but
he was he was a sicko
um he he did it to men uh
i could obviously dismember them would
keep body ate
some some of them body parts when they
caught them were in the freezer
i mean just know so when he went to
prison
he went to the pc section the protective
custody section right because he was
famous
you know they got a and even there
two attempts were made on his life the
second one being
being successful they killed him on the
second try and it was within like
a year or something and people go wow
you know
and that's you know i wonder why they
they tried so hard to kill him and the
thing is
you don't want some creep you know
around you you don't want somebody that
you don't know what they're gonna do
when you close your eyes you know
they're gonna try and saw your head off
or do
whichever right and nobody felt
comfortable with that dude around and he
had to go
okay that's what ended up happening with
steve
uh oh wow okay yeah he's he started kind
of getting
creepy you know um with just the things
he was doing
and it just came to the decision of of
the group that hey this this guy's
he needs to go he can't be what happens
though what happens when that happens
like is there an investigation
or does it just no okay so
okay what do you mean like like what
happens as far as like if somebody gets
hurt or killed or what happened
it's a homicide yeah it's murder most of
the time you know but it's always a
homicide
uh yeah so it's like a crime scene
investigation
they'll they'll lock the building down
you know everybody's got to go to their
cells or dorms depending on where you
live
they come in they do the pictures they
do the outlet i mean it's
it's like what you'd see on tv um and
they
they usually end up finding the person
that's responsible
uh but yeah uh it's
but it's not always a murder um
sometimes it's just
you know you beat him up or you do
something real
you hurt them real bad and then they go
you know so it just depends
so you're now the author of
thinking tough um which essentially
is what it says on on the book right
it's
essentially thinking tough it's you know
it's what it says which thing's great
um i want to talk about what's going on
in today's society because
it's sort of become a bit of a
personality trait to sort of have
depression and have anxiety
and um to be a victim you know everybody
sort of
celebrates victim mentality these days
so
you know why are people doing this what
do you think and how can we sort of
and why is that bad for society
especially in terms of
you know men taking on that kind of
mentality
well i i mean people
people tend to seek comfort and people
tend to shirk responsibility
so when you have that victim mentality
right you don't have to take
responsibility for anything
because it's something happening to you
you know it's not anything that you're
doing right because then you'd have to
be responsible
or anything you're not doing for that
matter right it's something happening to
you so you
you get to to not have to accept that
you're the one that that puts yourself
there
uh so comfort um
trying to shy away from responsibility
uh
and then really it's a
direction thing are
i i was lucky i was raised by somebody
that was raised by people that were born
in the 20s
okay so i kind of got like this
different um
feel uh this different education
uh and i and i noticed it from even my
high school years the way that my peers
would act you know and were different
and how they thought and whatnot
uh but a lot of that is
because the the generation you know
the boomers or or whatever you want to
call them uh
you they raise their kids
absence of this kind of toughness you
know oh we're not going to hit them
we're not going to yell at them we're
not going to
do anything to them we're going to just
you know baby them and do whatever
it it continued and it's created
what's just essentially soft men
i mean that's why i say it's good
the the way that you solve something
like that is that you
you have to have a mission
or or some type of challenge or some
type of something
put in in front of you repeatedly
um there was this uh
god i think it was uh starship troopers
and that's funny that i didn't remember
that for a second
because i have a family member that's in
that movie but uh
they they um that was a book originally
and they had like to where you did
mandatory
military service it was like if you
wanted to be a citizen you had to give
a couple years i think there's other
countries that actually do that i don't
know if it's israel
is it yes yeah you've got mandatory yeah
i i think that's a good thing i think
that's a good thing
you know i i can understand yeah yeah it
teaches you this responsibility and
it teaches you um it shows you the
underbelly depending on on the situation
and really makes you decide for yourself
hey am i gonna live or am i going to die
you know because essentially that's
everything's choices
but the big choices are that you know
it's like putting a roof over your head
or am i going to pay rent
or am i going to go to this party you
know it's like essentially they boil
down to that am i going to live or die
and so so yeah i think that there's just
too many
options and too many different avenues
that people can take
that just lead to comfort and shy away
from
i mean like look at what was that uh was
it
cosmo or something that put that picture
up
yes like come on man like
do you see what i mean it's just like
like so now we're just gonna just start
denying
the existence yeah yeah so for those
that don't know
yeah i'll just say for those that don't
know so i think on the front cover of
cosmopolitan
um magazine they had some clearly
overweight and obese women
posing and it had written this as
healthy even though we all know in
reality there's nothing healthy about
obesity
um so we're sort of like denying reality
to
not offend people um and that is just
the most ridiculous um surreal world to
live in which
i think we're just going to go down a
terrible kind of route if we continue
going down that that that kind of path
um but yeah it it's happening everywhere
um
i don't know what it is and i don't know
whether i don't know whether we're going
to go so far that we're sort of like do
a correction at some point um you know a
bit i guess a bit like financial markets
if you're gonna look at it like that but
we're absolutely denying reality in so
many different places and i think you're
totally right when you talk about
um you know parents and how they've sort
of had parents
have become softer and you even see this
in different cultures anyway you see in
so many different cultures african
parents compared to western parents
um very different and it's really
interesting to see
but i have an interesting question i
want to quickly chat to you about as
well because
when we met you told me that
you had spent the most of your life in
the states so you'd never actually left
the states before up until
you were until i don't know you are much
older and
so there's that but there's also you
were told that you were living in
not just the best country in the world
but in california which is the best
state in the world
in the best in the best city on the best
road in the best like
what like that is okay so so
here's what's up and i know that people
from from uh
the states are gonna probably not like
this this next comment coming out
but but if they're honest that if
they're honest
okay so americans
are told that this is the best country
on the planet
and and in a lot of ways from from when
i've when i've
the travels i've seen and stuff there
are a lot of ways to where
it is superior okay i will say that okay
but being from california we're told
that we live in the best state in the
best country on the planet
and very funny if you're from southern
california
right where the weather is nice and
where you know
it's like you can't deny it you're just
like yeah i do
i live in california there's the pacific
coast here's my beach
you know i'm i'm here here's my here's
my nice weather all year round
so yeah that is definitely something
that's just kind of
at least for me it was when i was a kid
it was just kind of drilled you know
into us it's just like man
we're in the best spot and you go
different places
and you see ways that maybe you're not
the best
but you also see you also see ways that
um
to where you are uh one one
one of the ways for example like when
we're talking about romania um
the people over there have much more of
a straightforward
attitude and more of a mind their own
business attitude as well
okay that's fantastic yeah which is
which is cool
you know so when you're talking to
someone they're just being you know okay
what it is
right right up front with you there's
there's no bs okay
and and they mind their business
you know you're playing your music a
little too loud nobody's gonna call the
cops
you know nobody's gonna do they don't
like that they don't like any of that
okay so that's cool however
america's cool and and the thing where
america in my opinion from what i've
seen thus far
has pretty much everybody be that is
america's
place to where you can get
anything with as much as you want
anytime you want it like it's just the
place to where it's just like the land
of plenty
right some place you need you need
something go right
now there's there's 400 stores that sell
it
you know i mean like it's just it's just
that place to where
you can get and there's we won't run out
you know like that that's another thing
it's like that that weird feeling that
um it's just there and when you go to
other countries and you see that like
okay they've only got two stores or okay
they
they only sell this or oh wow you can't
get this
and then you're just you kind of realize
like wow okay
we've just got everything over here
yeah it's insane i think america is just
a whole universe of its own
i mean forget the state being their own
thing anyway the
the the individual stakes just america
as a whole like you guys have a
have such an american mentality
in a way in in a way which is so
different to brits and i think the
the thing which really gets me is that
people often think like the uk and the
usa are sort of like
one of the same we speak the same
language we have very similar culture
and
you know we get on as if we're the same
but we're so
different so you've not been to the uk
but i spent i spent about three months
living in the u.s when i was
18 or 19 or whatever and i felt so
foreign
i felt so foreign like forget that the
money's different it was just like
the energy and the mentality and i was
working on a kid's summer camp
and the kids all broke out at one point
literally chanting u-s-a-u-s-a i
couldn't believe my eyes
couldn't believe it i was like
that's insane as if kids in the uk would
stop being like england
england no unless you're a football
match like yeah
yeah there definitely is an american
lens um
i had to catch myself you know i had to
catch myself when i was over and because
i was
over in romania for like 10 months or
something like that like
10 almost 11 months and are you done
there by the way are you going back
no no i'm i'm i'm here i'm here okay um
but uh it was it was definitely one of
those things to where there
is when when you're an american you go
other place there is this kind of lens
that you view things with
and i'd have to catch myself sometimes
during interactions because like
funny like we as americans
you know we have the freedom of speech
we have the freedom of this we have the
freedom of that
we've got guns we've got whatever we
just so like
if for me i'm going to speak my mind
you say something i'll say something
back you know like i'll just yeah you
know or whatever
like if you start getting stupid i'm
gonna call you on it like that's just
and in other cultures that's not
necessarily how it works
there there's a little bit of a game to
it you know and you don't
so i would have to catch myself
sometimes from being the
arrogant american you know or like the
[ __ ] american
you know because uh i was a guest in
another country and
and i didn't want to come across as you
know what not but there definitely is
is an american lens to when you go
different places for sure
i've got to tell you um americans are
great i love you guys so no one's taking
personally
a banter but like in the uk like when
you hear
like americans you're just like oh
americans
you're just like like troubles
yeah it's just like oh god they're gonna
be really loud they're gonna be really
obnoxious
like because brits we're just really
we're just like really tamed and we're
really you know we've got our stiff
upper lip and like we're just
and like it's funny because these
stereotypes don't come from nowhere you
know
um so i just think it's found i think
it's fascinating that you'd sort of said
you know
you thought you'd grown up in the best
country but not just the best country
the best state
it blew my mind but just with your whole
story in mind then
what would be kind of like the main or
like the biggest lesson that you've
learned the most
uh i think that the biggest the biggest
lesson
okay and this is for anybody that's
that's really struggling out there
that's watching or may hear this or
whatnot
first and foremost you have to take
responsibility
for your station meaning that wherever
you're at in life
whatever it is you're doing for a job
wherever you become
you know whatever that's you that's on
you
you chose that at some point okay so
once you realize that you are the one
that's putting yourself in situations
it's a negative situation realize that
you can put yourself
in a positive situation because you're
calling the shots for you
so take take responsibility for your
life
and come up with the plan of action to
get somewhere and not like a wish list
not like you know uh i want to be an
astronaut you know or i want to be
whichever that's that's a that's a wish
you know come up with with something
everything
anything that you want to be has been
laid out before you i got other people
have done it
yeah like journalism for example you
want to be a
be in journalism well there's uh you
know education you take for journey you
get three in this you get that you get
you call a station here you do whatever
the the steps are to apply and get in
it's it's been laid out so it's once you
commit
and and come to a plan of action then
you just have to put in the work
you put in the work and your time will
come like that yeah i think
that's what it does yeah i think it's
such an important thing to sort of make
clear because
i was thinking about this yesterday that
a lot of the time i'm talking about
personal responsibility
um people don't like it i think aoc sort
of said called the republicans the
responsibility party
as if it's a bad thing um which is
hilarious but but it's
it's the most incredible thing because
imagine being so out of control
like once you understand that you know
you can have that kind of responsibility
that's amazing imagine not having any
control of your life it just sounds
awful
yeah you know yeah for sure for sure
yeah it's something it's like it's like
being on the
the ocean right in a ship without a
rudder
like you just get blown to where i mean
if you're not taking responsibility
everything is happening
to you you aren't happening it's it's
it's being put on you and who'd want to
live like that
why would you want to live your life
like that yeah
you know and i think i and i think like
it shouldn't be a sort of um political
statement it shouldn't be a you know if
you take personal responsibility now
suddenly i know that you're more on this
end of the political spectrum not like
it should just be
um something fantastic and to empower
people and sort of say you know like
don't worry because actually you can
change that you don't have to wait for
the bureaucratic government to sign your
papers and
and say that you're approved and you
know we we agree you're worthy of it no
you can just go and do um and
i think i found the most amazing things
so bobby where can people
find you where can people reach you
where can they
find you so so i'm on twitter
at real bobby dino i'm also on uh
instagram under the same thing uh you
can read the articles
at bobbydino.com uh and
you know different places on social
media and shows like these but but
bobbydyno.com and twitter and this other
social media stuff is
is where to look perfect bobby thank you
so much
such a pleasure to have you on um and
guys don't forget to tune in next
thursday 12 p.m est
so thank you so much bobby hey thank you
for having me i appreciate it
alright bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]